BRENDAN O'BRIEN: Hello, and
welcome to Google I/O 2012.
Today, I'm going to be talking
about building web
applications that use Google
APIs and the JavaScript client
for Google APIs.
My name is Brendan O'Brien.
I'm a software engineering on
Google+, and I also maintain
the JavaScript client.
As the title implies, we're
going to be talking mainly
about the client, what it can
do, how you do that, and how
you use it to consume
Google's APIs.
So a little bit about
our APIs.
We provide many RESTful
APIs for most of our
products and services.
This includes Google+, Calendar,
Analytics, and over
35 more discovery-based APIs.
We even announced a few here
at Google I/O. Hopefully
you've seen some of
the sessions.
Requests are typically made to
www.googleapis.com, which is
Google's APIs front-end.
So I have an example here, since
it is a RESTful API.
I can take this URL and just
paste it into my browser here.
So what this one's going
to do-- let me
go back real quick--
as you can see in the URL here,
that urlshortener/v1.
This is going to go to URL
shortener API at version one,
and take this shortened URL,
and give us back the long,
full URL for it.
So if I paste that in, we should
get some data back.
And here we are.
We have a JSON blob, and
we can see one of
the fields is longUrl.
www.google.com.
So that's what the short
URL translates to.
And there's some other fields
in here that might be useful
for you as well.
So we also provided several API
clients to make accessing
the Google APIs easier
for you.
We have a total of nine
clients right now.
Besides just JavaScript, there's
Java, Objective-C,
Python, and many more.
And I have a link here, if
you're curious later, to see
all the clients that
we currently have.
So before, if you wanted to
consume Google APIs, you had
to do it from your web server,
using one of the server-side
scripting languages--
Java, Python, something
like that.
So in order to make API calls,
your code in the browser would
have to call back to your web
server, your web circles makes
a call to the Google APIs server
to get a response back,
and then it has to pass that
response back to the browser.
So a lot of logic must exist
on your web server to make
this possible.
Well, with the JavaScript
client, you can make these
calls directly from
the browser.
This makes your web server a
bit simpler, and also just
makes it so that you
can make these
direct calls a bit quicker.
So I'm going to do a
quick demo using
the JavaScript client.
And I have a little snippet
of code here.
This is basically all the code
that exists in the demo that
I'm about to show you.
This is all that's needed to
load an API and then make
calls to it and get
a response back.
So here is this demo.
Again, I'm going to use the URL
shorter API as an example.
And I'm going to take a short
URL and expand it
out into a long URL.
And you'll see that I've
pre-populated this field here
with the same short URL
that we had before.
So, if we expand it, as we
expect, we see that this short
URL expands to www.google.com.
And like I said, the code you
saw on the previous page is
all the code that's running on
this page besides HTML markup
and the little things to make
it slightly pretty.
So now that we've seen a demo
and seen what it can do, let's
talk in a little bit more detail
about what it provides
and what it can do.
First, a note on
compatibility.
We support the four major modern
browsers, including
Chrome, Firefox, Internet
Explorer, and Safari.
We also have built-in support
in the JavaScript client for
the OAuth 2.0 authorization
protocol so that your
applications can be authorized
to retrieve sensitive or
protected user data
on their behalf.
And we also support many APIs,
as I mentioned earlier.
I'm just going to click through
really quickly to the
Google APIs Explorer.
This is where you can see a list
of all the APIs we have
and what versions they're on,
and it also allows you to see
what methods are available
on each API.
What's also really cool is you
can run these methods directly
from the Google APIs Explorer
and play around with them
before actually implementing
any code in your project.
So it's very useful.
And I'll be doing a little
bit more with the
APIs Explorer later.
And also, if you are interested
and you attend the
code lab, we'll be doing
a lot more work in
the Explorer as well.
So let's just have a
quick look at it.
So we can see the list
of APIs here.
We can scroll down and see
the various versions.
There's a little description
on the right of the API and
exactly what it does.
So here's URL shortener down
here at the bottom, the one
we've been using.
If I click through it has all
the methods that are available
on URL shortener, what their
names are, and again, a quick
little description.
You can also see, at the top,
there's a link to the full
documentation for this API.
And that will tell you in detail
what the calls are that
can be made, how to make them,
what their response is going
to look like, et cetera.
So we'll come back to this
later when I actually
demonstrate exactly how you can
make calls from the APIs
Explorer to learn about
these calls.
OK.
So you're probably wondering,
well, what do I get by using
the JS client?
Well, the first thing is we have
a method that allows you
to make these RESTful
requests.
All of our APIs are based on
the REST protocol, which is
also the basis for HTTP.
URLs typically identify
resources, and then you
specify the HTTP verb, such as
POST or PUT or GET, that is
going to do an operation
on these resources.
So I have another snippet of
code here that shows how to
make a REST request in the
JavaScript client.
The method for that is
gapi.client.request.
All methods are on the
gapi.client namespace, or, for
our authorization method,
the gapi.auth namespace.
So this is the same example
I've been using so far.
This is the URL shortener API.
And we can see in the path,
like we saw before, I list
first the API I want, URL
shortener, and then the
version of it that I'm
trying to access.
And then, as I mentioned,
there's a resource at the end.
URL is the resource we're
trying to access here.
And then we pass in a few params
to let the API know
exactly what we want to do.
Since we pass in a short URL,
it knows that we want to get
back information about
this short URL.
In particular, what
does it expand to?
What's the long URL?
So when you call
gapi.client.request, you get
back a REST request object.
It hasn't actually made
the call yet.
In order to make the
call, you call
Execute on the REST request.
It's the only method
to find on it.
And it takes one parameter,
a callback function.
And I'll be talking about
that in a little more
detail later as well.
So the other way you can make
requests, or another request
format that we support,
is JSON-RPC.
When you make the request, it's
encapsulated is JSON data
in a POST body.
And the response is always JSON,
as the name implies.
So again, I have an example up
here of the same URL shortener
that we've been using.
And here you can see
the signature
looks a little different.
It says gapi.client.urls
hortener.url.get.
So if you remember from the
APIs Explorer, that's the
exact name of the method that
we're trying to execute.
And we can see, we can just call
it directly, pass in our
parameters that we're interested
about, and again,
we get back a request object.
This is now an RPC
request object.
But it's very similar
to REST request.
It has one method
on it, Execute.
You pass in a call back, and
when the function returns, you
can play around with
the response.
So, I also said that we have
a built in mechanism that
supports OAuth 2.0
authorization and
authentication.
Essentially, what you do is you
create a client ID-- and
we'll be going over that later
as well-- which identifies
your application.
And you also gather a set of
scopes that you'd like
to have access to.
So if you've ever installed an
Android application, for
example, it tells you what this
application wants to access.
Does it want to see
your location or
maybe read your profile?
So these are the kind of things
that scopes identify to
the OAuth server that you want
to access for this user.
So here in this example, I have
just a random client ID.
And then I have one scope that
I'm interested in here.
And this is the Calendar
scope.
So this will ask the user, this
application would like to
access your calendar, possibly
read and also possibly
manipulate.
Is that OK?
And we'll be seeing an example
of that later.
So the interface to do all OAuth
2.0 authentication is
gabi.auth.authorize.
You pass in the client ID I
mentioned, the scopes, and you
can request multiple
scopes if you need
access to multiple APIs.
And then we have this immediate
value, which I'll be
going over a little
bit more later.
Now, that's all contained in
one object, so that's the
first parameter.
The second parameter is another
callback method.
And this will be past the result
of authentication.
And if it's successful, you can
continue on and use your
application.
If not, you'll need to handle
the error somehow.
So now we know what
the Google API's
JavaScript client can do.
And I'm sure you're curious,
how do I do that?
I've shown you some brief
examples, but now I'm going to
go into a little bit more detail
about how exactly we
can do that and how
that works.
So two things I want to go
over before we begin.
The first is the APIs console.
This is where you create an
API key and a client ID.
Both are used to identify your
application when making requests.
And again, we'll be talking
about those more detail when I
go over authorization.
This is also where you activate
the APIs that you're
interested in.
So you saw a long list of APIs
in the APIs Explorer.
Well, you turn on the various
APIs that your application is
going to need access to.
And you can do more in
the APIs console
to manage your project.
You can change the quota
for the APIs.
They'll have a default amount of
quota that they're allowed
to access every day.
But you can request more
if you need more.
If your application's become
very popular, then you might
need to do that.
This is also where you
manage billings.
A few of our APIs are paid APIs,
and you have to set up
billing there.
And you can do team management,
as well, to add
more members to your project
so that they can go in and
also change these settings.
So I showed you the APIs
Explorer briefly.
This is, as I mentioned, a
great starting point for
documentation.
First, you can just go through
the list of all the methods
that are available on
the API and get a
brief overview of each.
And as you saw, there was
a link to the full
documentation, so you can find
out just everything you want
to know about this
particular API.
You can try the API calls out
from the Explorer as well.
And we're going to do
that right now.
So here's that short
URL again.
I hope you're noticing
a theme.
So we come back into the APIs
Explorer, and I want to find
the URL shortener API.
So here are all those
methods again.
And the description of the
first one says "expands a
short URL or gets creation
time and
analytics." Well, great.
That's exactly what
we're looking for.
I want to see what this
short URL expands to.
So I click into that, and it
gives me this form where I can
fill in the parameters
for this particular
method and let it go.
As you can see, the bold
red ones are required.
Let's get that up
a little bit.
So I'm going to paste in that
value here that we had before
for short URL, and execute
this method.
Now, if we scroll down, the
APIs Explorer shows us the
request that was made.
We saw this URL in the beginning
of the presentation.
And then it shows the
response as well.
And this is the same response
we saw earlier, a JSON
response where long URL has
the value that we're
interested in.
OK.
So now that we've done
that, we're ready
to use the JS client.
Well, to load it,
the URL is here.
It's https://apis.goo
gle.com/js/client.js.
Now, the way the JS client
loads, it loads asynchronously
in two phases.
We do this, obviously, so that
it doesn't block your page and
make performance terrible while
you're waiting for the
page to load.
But this also means you need to
know when the JS client is
actually loaded and
is ready to use.
So to do that, we have added
this onload parameter, URL
parameter, that you
add to the URL.
And it specifies a global
JavaScript function that it
should execute when the JS
client is ready to use.
So let me just highlight
those two things here.
We can see the URL for the JS
client and the script source
with this onload parameter.
And it's pointing to this global
init function which is
defined above.
And once the unit executes, we
know that the JS client has
loaded, and we can run off
and start consuming APIs.
So the first of the two ways you
can make requests in the
JavaScript client is by
making a REST request.
When you go into the
documentation, the full
documentation, for each API,
they tend to describe the APIs
in terms of REST.
So, what are the URLs that you
need to construct to access
various resources?
What are the methods
you need to make?
The HTTP methods you
need to use to
manipulate these resources?
So here, again, is the
REST request method.
We just call it
gapi.client.request.
And it takes one argument,
which is what we
call a bag of arguments.
It's just an object with key
value pairs of one required
and several optional
parameters.
So let's just go through
those very quickly.
The first is the 'path,' the
path to which you're making
this request, that identifies
the resource that you're
trying to get or manipulate.
Earlier, we saw that, for the
URL shortener, it was
urlshortener/v1/url.
So that last part, /url, is
the resource that we're
interested in.
Now you need that whole path
in the gapi.client.request,
and we'll see that
in a second.
The next parameter is 'params.'
These are URL
parameters that will be
serialized and encoded and
added to the path when
this request is made.
When going through the
documentation, some of the
APIs have URL parameters that
you can use to control how the
method is executed, or maybe how
the response comes back.
And so this is where you would
add those parameters.
Next, we have 'method,' which
is the HTTP method.
This is, again, optional.
It defaults to a GET.
But you can do, again, many APIs
support POSTs and DELETEs
and INSERTs, in particular,
for deleting and inserting
more resources.
And then next we have 'headers.'
this is a key value
pairing, again, of headers--
and it's optional--
that you can send along
with your requests.
These are, again, just
HTTP headers.
And some of the APIs have some
headers that you can set,
again, to control or manipulate
the request as it's
being made.
Next, we have a 'body,'
an HTTP body.
Particularly when doing inserts
and making REST
requests, you'll serialize a
JSON object into the body, and
that will get sent to the API.
And finally, we have
'callback.'
This is, again, optional.
But it's a callback function
that will be executed when the
request returns.
Now you don't have
to provide this.
If you do, the request is
executed immediately, because
it has a callback.
If not, you get the REST request
object back that we
saw earlier.
And then you can call execute on
that, and that's where you
would pass in the callback
function.
So here's an example.
I've switched APIs now to the
Calendar API, because it works
very well for this example.
So, we see in the path that
I want to specify the API
inversion that I'm interested
in-- calendar, v3.
And the documentation
will mention this.
And then I want to access
me, as a user.
So I put in users/me.
And in the documentation, "me"
is a special keyword to let
you know that it wants to access
the currently logged-in
users, so the users of your
applications, their Calendars.
And then the last
is calendarList.
I want to list all the Calendars
that this user has.
So then I have the method as a
POST, because what I want to
do for this request is insert
a new calendar.
So I'm posting to
this resource to
insert a new value.
Next, I set one header value,
which is content type
application JSON to let the
API server know that I'm
sending JSON data along
with this request.
Now, this is actually
the default.
It's always included.
But I've included it here
for illustration
of the headers parameter.
Next, we're passing
along a body.
So, as I mentioned, we're
inserting a new calendar here,
and this is how the API
expects the new
calendar to be inserted.
You pass in a calendar
resource, which the
documentation describes, to
create this new calendar.
So I've included one parameter
that's required, the ID, and
that's just my demo email
address here.
And I've also included an
optional parameter value, the
selected true.
And this will mean when you look
at the Calendar UI, that
this calendar will be selected
by default and you'll see your
events in the Calendar UI.
And then I pass in a callback
so that this request will
execute immediately.
And when it returns, it will
execute this function.
So let's talk a little bit
about that callback.
So the callback takes
two parameters.
The first is called
jsonResponse, and this is the
response from the response
body, parsed as JSON.
This will actually be the
Boolean value false if the
response is not valid JSON or if
it's just not JSON at all.
This could be the case for a
few APIs, but it's kind of
rare that you will not
have a jsonResponse.
If you don't, we also provide
rawResponse, which is the full
HTTP response as a stream.
So this is actually JSON.
Even though it is a string, you
can parse it out into an
object that contains the body
response, the headers, which
is another key value pairing and
object that were sent as
response headers, the status of
the request, and then the
status text as well.
So if you're interested in
anything besides the response
in the body-- the headers, the
status, or the statusText--
you would find that
in rawResponse.
So the other request format that
we can use is JSON-RPC.
And there's actually several
ways we can make a JSON-RPC
request using the JS client.
The first is by just directly
creating one of these objects.
So we do that with
gapi.client.rpcRequest.
And the format, as
you see here, is
it takes three arguments.
The first is the method
you want to execute.
The second is the API version
of the API that
you're trying to access.
And then the parameters for this
actual request are passed
on as the third argument here.
So I have a quick example.
This request is going to search
the Google+ profiles.
So that method is
plus.people.search.
You can find that, again,
in the APIs Explorer.
There's method name and what
the current version is.
In this case, it's V1.
And then we pass in an object,
key value pairing, of the
parameters that this
method expects.
So it only has one required
parameter, and that's the
query you want to make.
And so I'm going to look for
every profile on Google+ where
the person's name
includes Lewis.
So that returns back a
RpcRequest object to me, and
then I can execute that and
pass in a callback.
So you may remember from before,
I didn't use that
RpcRequest method when I
introduced JSON-RPC.
I called a method directly on
the gapi.client namespace.
Well, this is how
you set that up.
We have a gapi.client.register
method, which registers this
method that we're interested in,
so that we don't have to
always put in the method
name that we want.
And it's particularly
the API version that
we're interested in.
So when I do this call here,
gapi.client.register
('plus.people.search') and pass
in the apiVersion, that's
going to register this method.
And remember that the version
that we're interested in for
this method is V1.
So that method registers in
the gapi.client namespace.
We do this to avoid polluting
the global name space and keep
it as tight as possible.
And the way we register it is by
separating on the dots and
the method name and turning
that into a namespace and
function name.
So plus.people.search becomes
gapi.client.plus.people.search.
And then this is a method.
So when you execute this method,
you pass in the params
for the RpcRequest that
you're trying to make.
And again, it returns to
an RpcRequest object.
So in the example down here at
the bottom-- let me just
highlight that real
quick-- this is
where we call the method.
I pass in the same query that
I was interested in before.
I want to find everybody
named Lewis.
And I get a request
object back.
And then I can execute
that request object
and pass in a callback.
So now, with JSON-RPC, you can
load one in particular API,
the entire API, all at once so
that you don't have to, for
example, register every single
one of the methods.
We looked at URL shortener
earlier, and
there were three methods.
Well, some have quite a
few more than that.
They may have three dozen,
for example.
And you don't want to have to
put in your code a line
gapi.client.register for each
one of those methods if you're
going to be using them
most of the time.
So the JS client provides a
convenient method called load,
gapi.client.load, which will
load the entire API surface,
register all the methods, and
when we do that again, it will
remember the version that
we're interested in.
So this is a nice convenience
method that will save us some
time and some coding
in our code.
So the way this works is you
pass in the name of the API
you're interested in.
This is typically the first
part of the full method
description.
So in plus.people.search, the
first portion was "plus."
That's API name.
And then we pass in the version
we're interested in,
V1 in this case.
And then it also takes as a
third argument a callback to
let us know when that API has
loaded, all the methods are
registered, and we can start
making requests--
registered method requests--
on that API.
So this one, for example,
registers all
the Google+ API methods.
So we saw how to make
a JSON-RPC request.
We saw a couple methods of
making a JSON-RPC request.
And in all of them, we
pass in a callback to
this execute method.
So this callback is very similar
to the REST callback,
in which we get two parameters
passed to this callback.
The first is JSON response.
Again, this extracts the
returned value from the HTTP
request, parses it
at JSON, and then
passes it as this parameter.
And again, this will be false
if the response is not valid
Jason or not JSON at all.
But of course, since we're
working with JSON-RPC, that is
going to be extremely rare,
if it ever happens at all.
But, just in case, we include
the rawResponse, which is the
entire RPC response
as a string.
It's always present, but
you may not always be
interested in it.
So again, if it's not JSON,
you can do your own custom
parsing on this.
But again, I don't think
that'll be a
very common use case.
So one cool thing about JSON-RPC
requests is we have
built-in support for making
batch requests.
So you have a snippet in
your code that makes
many requests in order.
And for each one of those, it's
going to be making an
HTTP round trip.
And these are HTTPS
round trips.
All of our requests
are made on SSL.
So they can be quite costly.
If you're making many of them,
it would be nice if you could
make multiple requests with
just one HTTP round trip.
Well, this is what batching
allows you to do.
All requests are sent off and
executed in parallel, and then
they all come back at
the same time with
their various responses.
So let's go through, quickly,
how you use
the JSON-RPC batching.
Well, the first step,
up at the top, is
create a new batch.
And that method is
gapi.client.newRpcBatch.
And this gives you back
a batch object.
We can then add requests to
the batch object, and when
we're done adding requests, we
can execute it and go and get
our responses back.
So the next two segments
we see here is
the add method, batch.add.
Let me show you first
in the code.
I created two RpcRequests.
Just for illustration, one is
a direct creation, where I
call RpcRequest and pass in the
method and the API name
that I'm interested in.
And this one's going to search
for all Google+ profiles where
the person's name
contains Larry.
And then I create another
request from the register
plus.people.search method.
And you can see, in this case,
it's a little bit simpler.
All I have to pass in now is the
query parameters that I'm
interested.
And so then this request is
going to search for all people
on Google+ name Sergey.
So now I want to add both these
requests to my batch and
then execute the batch.
Well, in the batch.add, the
first parameter, the first
argument to this method--
it takes two--
is required, and it's the
request you want to make.
Makes sense.
The second argument is another
one of these bag of args with
some optional parameters
in it.
The first is going to be the
ID for this request.
So obviously, you're
making multiple
batched requests here.
When it returns, it may not
necessarily be in the same
order as you added them
to the batch.
It just depends on when
those requests
finish on the back end.
So if you want to be able to
access the response from this
entire batch, you'll need
an ID for that.
So for the Larry request,
I've added an ID.
We're just going to call it
"Larry." So that will identify
my response.
I've also passed
in a callback.
And I defined this callback
up above.
Right now it's just
an empty function.
But you can see it's got the
same callback signature that
we've seen before.
For the second request, I add
it, and I don't use any of
optional parameters.
Now, if you're interested in
the response for a batch,
you're going to want one of
the two, ID or callback.
You'll either want the ID to
extract a response from your
batch response, or
the callback.
Because this individual callback
will be called with
just the response for this batch
operation, not for the
entire thing.
So once I've added two requests
to my batch, I define
a batch callback.
Again, this is just an empty
function for illustration
purposes, but you can see that
the signature is similar to
what we've seen before.
I'm going to go over that
in detail in a second.
And then I execute that
batch and pass
in the batch callback.
So a little bit about
these callbacks.
As I mentioned, there
are callbacks
for individual responses.
You saw we added one for the
Larry request, but not for the
Sergey request.
And then we also, when we
executed the overall batch
operation, we sent in another
callback method.
So how do these get executed
when the response returns?
Well, individual batch
callbacks are
all executed first.
You're not guaranteed the
order, but you will be
guaranteed that those
will execute first.
And then when all those are
done, the overall batch
callback is executed.
So what gets passed to these
callbacks when the response
has returned?
Well, again, it's very similar
to what we've seen before for
JSON-RPC requests.
The first is a JSON response.
This is the response parsed as
JSON, so you get a JavaScript
object back.
For individual callbacks, this
is the response, as I said,
just for that particular
method.
So the Larry callback we saw
will be executed and only
receive the response from the
search for people named Larry.
It will not see the response
for Sergey
in this JSON response.
For batch callbacks, this
is all of the responses.
And it's a map of the batch ID
to the particular response for
that batch operation.
And then the second parameter is
the best response, which is
the same overall ID to response
mapping, but this is
just a string.
What's nice about this is it
always includes the full batch
response for both individual
callbacks and
for the overall callback.
So at the end of one of your
individual callbacks, you're
going to need to access data
from another batch operation
you've made.
You could either look in this
batch response, or you can
also use the overall batch
callback, as that will receive
the ID to response mapping as
well, but that time in the
JSON response parameter.
So, I have an example down here
from our previous slide.
Those requests we made
in the batch.
We get a response back,
which is just an
ID to response pairing.
The first ID is Larry, since we
specified what ID we want
that response to be
identified with.
And then the second one is just
a random string that the
JS client automatically assigned
for you so that it
has a unique ID identified
with it.
And then each one of these has
the individual responses, the
search results for Larry and the
search results for Sergey.
OK, so now we're going to
diverge just a little bit.
We saw the two request
formats that you can
use with the JS client.
One is the RESTful style,
the other is JSON-RPC.
Well, we also provide an option
for using a different
transport for making
these requests.
So, astute observers will notice
that we're making calls
to www.googleapis.com
from your domain.
Your application is running
on a different domain.
We're not going to let you
run on googleapis.com.
Well, you can't make
XML HTTP requests
to a different domain.
That's not allowed
by browsers.
Well, the JS client gets around
this in a somewhat
clever way, but it's also a
little bit bulky, and it's
proprietary as well.
But there's a new transport out
there called CORS, which
stands for Cross Origin
Resources Sharing.
So if the server that is
accepting XML HTTP requests
support CORS and says CORS
will be allowed for these
requests, then you can
make a CORS request.
And so we've implemented
this on googleapis.com.
So you can make direct
XHRs to Google APIs
and access our APIs.
So these are constructed similar
to REST requests,
because we're just making HTTP
requests and, as you may know,
that those are based on
the REST protocol.
So I have a snippet here, and
what's cool about this snippet
I've included is you can take
all this code, copy it into a
page, make a request,
and it will work--
well, with one caveat.
I've provided a dummy
API key here.
But if you change that and put
in your own API key, this
would work just fine.
So we can see, in this
example, some of the
translations that
we need to make.
So when you open an XHR, the
first parameter is the HTTP
method you want to make.
So that was provided in
gapi.client.request.
Here's where you put it here.
And then the second parameter is
where you want to make the
request to.
So you can see, I have
to include a bit
more in this example.
I have to include the domain
I want, www.googleapis.com.
And now there's this new
parameter key with this sort
of encrypted value here, and
what the heck is that?
Well when making requests,
you must identify your
application, either using
an API key or client ID.
We'll get back to this again a
little bit more when we talk
about authentication.
Normally, the JS client, you
set the API key once, it
remembers it, and for every
request this key is set.
Well, if you're making a CORS
requests, you're not
using the JS client.
And so you need to remember
to add that.
The same is true for this
request header here, Content
Type Application JSON.
I included that in the REST
example earlier, for
illustration purposes, and
mentioned that the JS client
will handle this for you.
Well, if you're making direct
requests through CORS, you
need to remember to
set this as well.
The callback is set by sending
a function to the onload
parameter and getting the
response from the
XHR response text.
And we send the payload in the
body through the xhr.send.
So in this example, I'm actually
inserting a long URL
to try to get back the shortened
version for it.
So when I send the request,
I pass in the long URL,
www.google.com.
So why did I mentioned this?
Well, first, we just think
CORS is pretty cool.
It's a native transport, which
means you don't need to use,
as I mentioned, our proprietary,
cross-domain
handling method, which
means it allows for
faster requests overall.
It's also standards-compliant,
non-proprietary, and it's
native to most major
modern browsers.
So I encourage you, if you're
interested, to try out CORS
request, but with a
couple caveats.
One is that browser support
is currently not quite as
expansive as the JS client.
So the JS client will handle
pretty much any major modern
browser that your users
are using, but CORS is
not quite there yet.
Also, since it's not currently
implemented in the JS client,
if you stop using the JS client,
you'll miss future
updates to the JS client.
So that's why I mentioned
to use, maybe, as an
experimental basis.
Or perhaps you know that your
users are only using compliant
browsers, and so you just want
to use CORS instead.
That's a great use
case for that.
So I've included a useful link
here to caniuse.com, which
will tell you which browsers and
which versions currently
support this.
So let's summarize, first, the
two request formats that I've
mentioned here.
The one is JSON-RPC, and
the other is REST.
So, which allows you to set and
read HTTP method headers
and bodies?
Well, the REST does,
as we saw.
It had those various
parameters that
you can pass in.
JSON-RPC does not.
It only allows you to
pass the parameters
that the API expects.
What about batching?
Well, JSON-RPC has built-in
batching.
We saw that earlier.
It was pretty easy to do.
There's just a few method calls
you need to make to get
that to work.
REST also supports batching,
but it's quite a bit more
tricky to do, and it's not
built into the JS client
currently, so you'll have
to do it by hand and
really kind of messy.
I definitely suggest, for right
now, using JSON-RPC if
you want to do batching.
And we also saw that, with
JSON-RPC, we can auto-load
full APIs, register all those
methods, and then make these
really simple requests on them
but just passing in the query
parameters that the
API expects.
Whereas, with REST, you pretty
much need to construct every
single request manually
by hand.
We also have two transports.
One is built into
the JS client.
We call that XD3.
And the other is CORS,
as I mentioned.
Well, if you use the JS client,
then your requests are
automatically formatted.
So I mentioned before that
CORS requests generally
translate well to
REST requests.
Well, you can also make a
JSON-RPC request using CORS if
you get the format right.
Well, the JS client handles
the format for you, so you
don't have to worry
about that.
And it can be maybe a
little bit tricky.
So CORS doesn't allow you to do
that, at least currently.
The JS client is fully
cross-browser compatible.
We saw all the clients
that it supports.
That'll cover most modern
browsers, major browsers,
whereas CORS only has
partial, currently.
However, CORS is native to the
browsers that do support it,
whereas the JS client,
obviously, is not, and you
need to download that into
your application.
JS client has built-in Auth,
however, and allows us to make
these OAuth 2.0 authentication
and authorization, whereas
CORS does not.
Those endpoints don't support
CORS currently, so you'll
still need to use the JS client
if you want to do
authorization.
Let's talk about
This is the last major
piece of the JS
client that it provides.
So just a very quick
OAuth 2.0 overview.
This is probably review
for most of you.
It's in the webinar, if you've
seen the webinar.
And there's also some
talks at Google I/O
that talk about OAuth.
But just a quick overview.
I found a great quote
for this.
"OAuth is a security protocol
that enables users to grant
third-party access to their web
resources without sharing
their password."
So normally, if we did not have
OAuth, the user would
have to give your application
their username and password so
that you could sign into Google
for them and make
requests to the Google
API servers.
Well, with OAuth, that's
no longer necessary.
Instead, the user logs in
directly to this third party--
in this case, the Google
APIs server--
and gets back an access token.
And then your application uses
that access token to make
requests to protect
your resources
on the user's behalf.
So I have a few useful links
here to the OAuth working
draft, a page on the Google
Developers page about OAuth
and how to use it and everything
that provides and
what we support, and then a nice
intro from universe.com,
which is where I got this great
quote here that briefly
describes OAuth 2.0.
So let's look at that, quickly,
in an example.
I want to show the difference
between authorization and
authentication, because
I think I might be
a little bit unclear.
So this example, as it says,
is going to retrieve my
profile name and photo using
the Google+ API.
So I click this Authorize
button here.
And the first thing it does is
pop up a Google-- this is
accounts.google.com,
as you can see.
This is the Google login page.
So I need to provide my email
here and password.
And then I sign in.
That's the authentication part
that authenticates me with
Google servers only,
not your servers.
And then the next page it
brings me to is the
authorization page, where
the user authorizes your
application to make requests
on their behalf.
So we can see that my app, I/O
2012 JS Client Demos, is
requesting permission to know
who I am on Google, so it can
get my profile name
and picture.
And if I expand that, it tells
you a little bit more.
Associate you with your
Google profile.
So this segment here comes from
those scopes that you
pass when you do
gapi.auth.authorize.
And again, there can
be many of these.
So the user can click Allow
Access or no, No Thanks, I'm
not interested.
Of course, I'm going to click
Allow Access here.
And there you go, it retrieves
my name and my little Android
figure avatar here.
So I've been talking about the
API key and client ID a bit.
Let's go over what exactly
those are.
Now, if your application is
accessing unprotected
resources, then all you
need is the API key.
And all it does is identify your
application is accessing
these APIs.
And that's important for quota
and things like that.
However, for protected
resources, we need to make
sure that you're authorized
to access
these protected resources.
And so that's when you exchange
a client ID to our
Google authorization servers to
get an access token back,
and then you pass that access
token with each request to
access-protected resources.
So let's go over, really
quickly, where you get this
API keys and client IDs.
So I'm going to the APIs console
here that we saw
earlier, and I'm going to
create a new project.
And when we create the project,
the first place it
takes us is to the
Services page.
And this is where you turn on
all the various APIs that
you're interested in.
I've been using a
few examples, so
let's turn those on.
I'm going to turn on
Calendar first.
And you can see what it does is
it sends me to a Terms of
Service page to make sure I
agree to the terms of service,
first for Google APIs
is in general--
I accept--
and then for the Calendar
API in particular.
I'm going to go ahead and
agree to those as well.
And then we've been
using Google+.
Let me turn that one on.
And again, there's the
Google+ Terms of
Service, so I accept that.
And finally, we've been using
URL Shortener as well.
So let's turn that one on.
And in that case there is no
Terms of Service for the URL
Shortener, so we don't
see anything there.
So now that I've turned on the
APIs that I'm interested in,
we'll go to the API
Access tab.
And we can see already under
Simple API Access that there
is an API key here.
Just highlight that quickly.
This is that key that sent along
with the request you saw
earlier, and it will identify
your application for
unprotected resources.
However, if we want to access
protected resources, we need
an OAuth 2.0 client ID.
So let's create one with
this blue button here.
First thing you do is put
in your product name.
So when we saw that
authorization window, it said
I/O 2012 JS Client Demos.
Let's put that in.
You can also put a logo, and
this will show up on that same
page, too, to identify
your application.
I'm just going to skip
that for now.
So it asks you what your
application type is.
Of course, in this case, we're
building web applications, so
we choose Web Application.
And then down here it asks for
your site or host name.
I'm going to expand this to get
a few more options here.
So this first box, Authorize
Redirect URIs, is not going to
apply in our case, because we're
not doing that kind of
authorization.
If you go to the OAuth 2.0 talk,
they'll talk about that
a little bit more and
what that does.
We're just curious about this
authorized JavaScript origin,
because we're making JavaScript
requests.
So you can see here, it's
defaulted to www.example.com.
Well, as a developer, this
is the domain that your
application is running on.
Well, let's just say mine is
running on google.com.
Now, when verifying these
origins, they
need to match exactly.
So I have the HTTPS
protocol here--
that needs to be listed--
and then the full domain.
And also, if you're going to
be using a port, the port
should be listed here.
So I'm going to go ahead and
create this client ID to run
my application on secure
google.com.
And now we have a client ID.
So this is what's used to pass
to the authorized call to get
back an access token so that
your application can use that
access token to start
making requests.
Now, again, if you're using
the JS client, when that
access token gets returned, the
JS client will save it for
you locally, and then whenever
you make a request, that
access token will automatically
be sent.
Now, if you're sending an access
token, you don't also
have to send an API key,
but it doesn't hurt to.
So I generally recommend to
always set the API key.
And then, even if you're using
a client ID, the access token
gets sent as well, and
everything works just fine.
OK.
So I'm just going to go over
a code snippet here.
And again, I included all this
code because this is just
about everything you need
to do to make a nice
authorization experience
for your application.
So I'm going to go through
what this does.
First, at the top here, we
have this global init
function, which is going
to be executed when
the JS client loads.
We saw that earlier.
First thing I do is
I set the API key.
Now, I have a variable API key
above here that I don't show,
but this is the key you saw
in the APIs console.
And then the next thing I'm
going to do is call this
checkAuth function here, which
is going to make a
gapi.auth.authorize call.
And to that, I passed the
client ID that we just
created, the scopes that I'm
interested in-- and we saw we
can have Calendar, maybe, or if
you're using Google+, you
want to say that you're going
to use the Google+ scope--
and then the last value I
pass is immediate true.
Now, what this is going to do
is do a behind-the-scenes
check to see, hey, has this user
already authorized your
application?
If so, terrific.
And if they're signed in, of
course, we'll give you back an
access token and you're
off and running.
Otherwise, you're going to need
to send the user through
the authorization flow.
So when this returns, it's
going to call this
handleAuthResult function and
pass in an Auth result.
We need to check that Auth
result to see, first, if it
exists, and if it does,
make sure that
there's no error there.
And if there is an error, we're
going to need to handle
that somehow.
Otherwise, we get an access
token back and we
can make API calls.
Great.
But if we have no AuthResult
or an error-- and an error
would be this immediate
has failed--
then we need to send them
through the full flow.
And to do that, I set this
handleAuthClick method to an
onClick handler for an
authorized button on the page.
Now, it's important that you
have this function kicked off
by a user-initiated event such
as a click or keydown,
because, as you saw earlier,
the flow uses a pop-up, and
you could trigger pop-up
blockers if you try to do it
just programmatically.
So here's that AuthClick
method down here.
And again, I'm calling
gapi.auth.authorize.
Pass the client ID in
the same scope.
But this time, I say I want
the immediate mode false.
Turn it off.
And this will send the user
through the pop-up flow that
we saw earlier.
Then we're passing the same
handleAuthResult because, when
we do get a response, an
AuthResult, then we know we're
good to go and we can
go off and running.
So one more thing I want to
mention is when you get this
access token, it expires after
a certain amount of time so
that you can't use it
indefinitely to make spammy
applications, for example.
Well, the response has another
field in it besides access
token, called expires_in.
And this is the value in seconds
until this access
token expires.
So what I've done in
this example here
is I take that value--
it's in seconds again-- and
I subtract 5 minutes--
5 times 60 seconds--
and then convert that to
milliseconds So that I can do
a set timeout to do the same
check off we saw before.
And this does that background
check to
get your access token.
So it can happen without
interrupting the user while
they're using the application.
And so by doing it this way,
you ensure that you have a
fresh access token
all the time.
I should also note that this
field expires and does not
auto update.
So there is a method,
gapi.auth.getToken, that gets
back this token value with
the expires_in field.
Well, that field
doesn't update.
So don't trust it when you
call gapi.auth.getToken.
Only trust it in this
handleAuthResult callback
So you make and authorized
call.
Like I mentioned, this is done
for you automatically by the
JS client, but if you're
using CORS you
need to set this yourself.
And the way you do that is you
set up one header, called
Authorization, where the value
is the string bearer plus the
access token.
And this is an example of an
access token which is, of
course, long since expired.
And that's it.
So I've included some
links here for you.
The first is the home page for
the JavaScript client.
The second is the discussion
forum.
If you want to ask questions,
I'm on the
discussion fairly regularly.
And then an announcement blog.
The name is wrong there, but
this is the link to the
announcements log where I
announce various new features
for the JS client.
And then I also wanted
to call out a couple
sessions and code labs.
There is a code lab for this
particular session that I very
much encourage you to go to.
It will go through all these
things I've talked about in
much more detail, and you'll
actually build an application
using the JS client.
You can also go to Optimizing
Your Code Using Features of
Google APIs, which is a session
on making your APIs
access more performant.
And finally, a session
on OAuth 2.0 and how
exactly that works.
So thank you very much
for coming today.
I would like to open up the room
for questions if you have
them, and if so, please use
the microphone so that the
folks on video can hear.
Thank you.